[Applaus]
die tornado jagd beginnt im
amerikanischen bundesstaat texas
im mai geht hier nämlich die tornado
saison los dominik reist mit seinem
freund sascha die beiden storm chaser
haben sich vor elf jahren in der schweiz
kennengelernt
die aufgaben sind klar verteilt
sascha sitzt am steuer und dominik sucht
am laptop nach sturz allen
betriebsformen versicherungs faszination
von der natur und der effekt 11 8 sehe
was zweiter machen und die kraft von der
natur das kann man einfach hier extrem
gut spüre hier der staat wie geht's rauf
die energie für ihre tat also wenn man
das anders erfolgserlebnis hat das liegt
mir mit dass sie jetzt die drei wochen
starte wollen jetzt hier
dann wird die fas ganzes jahr zeit
[Musik]
es ist erstaunlich welche dominanteste
mehr oder weniger sein
über ein jahr lang haben die beiden die
reise vorbereitet
jetzt müssen sie nur noch zur richtigen
zeit am richtigen ort sein
[Musik]
botswana im süden des afrikanischen
kontinents hier lebt der schweizer
christian gross er hat vor sechs jahren
die okawango air rescue gegründet eine
rettungsflugwacht ähnlich der schweizer
rega und jetzt flügelmann patrone
decknamen mit patienten und ich danke
ihr pc minute mühelos aus dem haus
geborgen
christian ist unternehmer die einsätze
fliegt sein team meistens mit dabei ist
auch micha krupp sie ist notfall ärztin
und christians lebenspartnerin mit
dieser pc 12 aus der schweiz hebt sie
fast täglich an um leben zu retten
heute haben wir ein acht tage altes
neugeborenes
da ist eine sog
hans position der großen gefäße hat
das heißt
anschlüsse vom herz
schulungen
nicht in der richtigen reihenfolge
und
dadurch
bekommt das kind nicht genug sauerstoff
in sein
system
und wenn man das nicht operativ
[Musik]
ja
die herausforderung ist dass diese
vom herzen
nicht durch zu die sauerstoff habe
geschlossen wird
[Musik]
absolut
bis so
[Musik]
die basis der okavango air rescue liegt
im städtchen mitten im okavango-delta
die gegend ist bekannt für ihre vielen
wilden tiere und beliebt bei touristen
von hier aus liegt das team von mischa
und christian seine einsätze in das
unwegsame gebiet des okawango flusses
für den weltenbummler christian ist
botswana ein zuhause geworden
[Musik]
knapp 20 der schweiz haben wir es ganz
hell haben die muschel und klappt mit
dem botswana wo er ist sagte funk zion
ihre natürliche zwei jahre sind
glücklich die misstrauische sie zum nur
knapp nachdem der jahr überleben würden
aber es entsteht die gewachsene jedes
jahr
wir haben rund rihs klar gestellt dort
davor sind im moment vier jetzt vier
piloten und krankenschwestern parametrix
notfallsanitäter und somit ist das
funktioniere ich wurde sondern in folge
und das ist groß
[Musik]
mittlerweile landen mischer und ihre
crew in sopron hier wartet ein vier
monate alter patient auf den
lebenswichtigen flug ins spital nach
durban
[Musik]
wie ist dein name kensington willkommen
in unserem kleinen flugzeug einsinken
hast du gehört du bekommst ein
privatflugzeugen
lasst uns kurz hallo sei das ist kern
sinkt und kensington schlägt nach dürren
für eine große operation und jetzt
bringen wir ihn in unser kleines bett
und machen es ihm dort schön bequem
[Musik]
sky könnte bereit
für mich und ich kann diese in der luft
hoffe ich bevor elvis jetzt wolf jagt
man nur für zwei tage und an ihn auf
spanien gut zu machen und hat 1600
die atmosphäre war sehr angespannt
und das war eine kleine gruppe von sechs
leuten
und die dame auf der andere sieht das
hasst mich auf sie und sie hat jeder bar
geschafft und wollen ich glaube ihm in
ihrer jagd luft ganz versperrt das
flugzeug habe hat sich mein team aus den
bergen der flugmaschine zum ersten mal
im leben
wahrgenommen
kein wort verstand
auch so ein sozialfall dem bis jetzt
hält der höhe
die hand ist auch für sich sympathisch
gefunden
und ja meist stream
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück in die schweiz
nach abriss will im kanton thurgau
auf diesen tag hat jonas langenecker
sehnsüchtig gewartet
heute kann er zum ersten mal seinen
neuen segel kunstflieger ausprobieren
aber zuerst muss er fertig
zusammengebaut werden
[Musik]
also mache ich den berg war wichtig ist
der link zur studie schnell einen
eigenen flügel im ernst ich halt neue
flügel und jetzt der kreuzung sowieso
sagte aber es hat sich halt anders
und ja ich bin ja schon seit ich mache
wäre schade dass in den kleinen flieger
noch geringer zum lupe okay du hast auf
rallye acht look frischen duft von
arbeit ich zeige ihnen irgendwie schafft
es nicht ganz
hast du mal nen pc over a ja logisch so
muss darüber ob das stimmt ja sie ist
noch jung und wenn welche symbolische
flügger dass ich alles klar dass mit
andern und dennoch einmal die erste
flügels problem genau mal am flügger
töne das gab es wichtig 2018 wurde jonas
weltmeister im segelkunstflug und zwar
in der kategorie etwa jochen reutter ist
sein trainer als bei mäusen rhön kreis
ist im prinzip des anfang an wichtig du
liebst ihn leicht aus dass konstant
anfang wirklich bewusst machen wie mit
der 21 und jetzt schiebt er so hin und
gibt seit oder oben und schoss die nase
oben
und jetzt geht schon automatisch jetzt
stößt dann einfach durch sagt hast die
ersten 45 er nach drehst weiter die
seiten oder in kurven richtung drehst
weiter das seitenruder bleibt immer noch
ist jetzt oben
wenn es weiter so und jetzt genauso wie
vor die nation das ganz anders als das
normale fliegen
die eindrücke die man hat die
beschleunigung die geschwindigkeit der
horizont man hängt in den gurten der
flüge schiebt das ist so verschieden vom
normalen fliegen dass man das wirklich
lange und ausführlich üben muss
[Musik]
hab ich schnell 100 100
das flugblatt es gewöhnt dass man es an
die kenntnis weiterreicht sondern auch
für heute sind es junge leute die das
dann wirklich umsetzen und teilweise das
genauso machen wie man es gern selber
gemacht
[Musik]
bei solchen figuren wirken enorme kräfte
von 7 g jonas wird mit dem siebenfachen
seines gewichts in den sitz gedrückt
[Musik]
jede bewegung wird vom trainer genau
beobachtet dieser spricht dass friedberg
auf ein diktiergerät die
drehgeschwindigkeit aufpassen hat die
erste von ungefähr 25 grad und und der
rest auf 80
der ist auf jeden fall das talent und
zwar ganz ausgesprochen gutes was sie
natürlich dazu verführt machen wir
zurücklagen alles geht von selbst das
tut es nicht
aber das gehört zur entwicklung von
sportler auch dazu
dieses programm bei jonas an den
schweizer meisterschaften in drei
monaten vor einer punkte jury finden im
prinzip für den ersten flug war das
nicht schlecht das war genau die
typischen probleme auftreten
zur frage der zeit bis das gut glaubt
macht spaß macht spaß aber geht da noch
einiges lernen
ja also videos der figuren und ich sage
dir diesen oder erst das was in europa
glück war der 25-jährige ist ein
ausnahmetalent
er will sein können in diesem jahr in
der höchsten segelflug kategorie
beweisen der unlimited klasse bekannten
figuren war gut von dem unbekannten und
uns wirklich dem spiel gleich von anfang
an ein bisserl exakte akzentuierte im
prinzip das gleiche nummer eins ziel ist
dass jeder schritt zur meisterschaft des
protests pflege ist natürlich auch lesen
konnte druckvoll in der kategorie
meisterschaft keine hand jetzt wird halt
auch wenn's genehm ist jetzt voll können
infiziert doch dort ist die luft denn
nur die besten treten gegeneinander an
bald wird sich zeigen ob jonas mit ihnen
mithalten kann
ein paar tausend kilometer weiter
westlich
die schweizer sturmjäger dominique und
sascha sind auf dem weg nach nebraska
ins tornado gebiet
in der nähe von el reno legen sie einen
zwischenstopp bei einer gedenkstätte ein
hier sind drei storm chaser auf ihrer
jagd nach den riesen stürmen ums leben
gekommen
aber im 15 ist max sieht die ganze darf
alles schon gemacht
36 sexy und das zerstören der tonart um
erinnerungen an gang und sorgt sich dass
der rhinower große tonart ak und humor
und endlich kann aber tonnato tanzen und
sie so vom nach längerem verboten und
die teams im o-ton den xi das auto
abgeschleppt und die chefs sind nach
winterberg spendiert worte während der
polo und karl die sie uns im auto
richtig umsätze erwarten sie nun ein
sicherheitscode sie angeschaut sie aber
sommer große kafka dass sie quasi wortes
motor gegenstand gefunden hat motorola
verteilt
[Musik]
sicherheit geht vor zwei nicht und das
ist wichtig angezogen von der magie der
naturgewalt fasziniert von der möglichen
gefahr steuern dominique und sascha auf
die gewitterzelle zu aus der ein tornado
werden soll
[Musik]
die aktuelle prognose modell porno sein
amt das zeigt aber möglich
das heißt ich sehe was verbindet da was
haben für eine wenig dass sie stehen
wenn sie also daher somit von steffi
dass da passt und dass ein tornado
begünstigt eine mauer supersauber hey wo
die menüs ist engagiert das heißt also
wir sind dort bei 4 sturm die
rechtsstellung sein dass er ist mit 9 12
stunden vorher nach dem woher das mit
dvi oder die prognose wurde angeregt die
arbeit ermöglicht die ganz starke
klickte sich wo ist eigentlich wirklich
interessieren
das ist
[Musik]
auch im sanktgallischen ahnt wie lebt
ein mann der sich mit leib und seele dem
element luft verschrieben hat in seiner
werkstatt bereitet sich ballon pilot
stefan zeeh bmw auf eine abenteuerliche
reise vor mit seinem co-piloten urs wild
stefan in argentinien auf 7000 meter
über meer aufsteigen und mit dem ballon
über die anden fahren als
professioneller ballonfahrer unternimmt
stefan rund 200 fahrten pro jahr
aber keine ist vergleichbar mit dem was
er in argentinien vor hat kragl
vorbereitete fragen
also das heißt auch ballett ist die
palette mitte spedition aus spanien
demetriou fragen dinge und darf man
natürlich bei den funktionären der
ballon hängt jetzt schneller als brenda
walsh trophy richtig checken und 2000
rücken wir das realisieren können
vermieden oder vater gebirge wo man
natürlich sehr höher stiegen daneben um
1 uhr stoffen gemacht mit dem faktor
romane trachtler sicher 40 körperlich
fit halten balompie 22 daher hat rund 22
liter nur die besten piloten der welt
trauen sich eine solche fahrt zu die
bedingungen sind extrem oder im buch
lange fahrt plötzlich allein das sind
challenge diese verträge wo man halt
rein mitte neue gegend oder hat weiter
es ist wirklich vertraut und
durchschnitt eigene erfahrungswerte
karli bringen wir schon mal sicher der
grund schwierigkeiten eine fremde land
die fahrt über die anden wird von einem
profi organisiert josef hat 50
ballonfahrer aus der ganzen welt dazu
eingeladen stefan gehört zu den
erfahrensten piloten der gruppe und
hilft darum bei den vorbereitungen
ich glaube das ist die komplizierteste
reise die er organisiert habe die winde
sind sehr stark und die einzige chance
die wir haben ist während diesen kurzen
zeitfenstern also lasst uns hoffen wir
brauchen schon ein bisschen glück nebst
all den üblichen herausforderungen
wartet dieses mal ein ganz besonderes
naturspektakel auf die ballonfahrer eine
totale sonnenfinsternis im westen
argentiniens
wir müssen zur richtigen zeit an
vordefinierten ort seien zur richtigen
zeit auf der richtigen höhe also die
sonnenbrille nicht vergessen da ich mir
ein paar shows highlight ich stelle mir
da natürlich auch extrem spannend vor
kurzem minute wo wirklich totale
dunkelheit am tag eine schmale streifen
um diese totale sonnenfinsternis aus dem
ballon mitzuerleben bord stefan beste
wetterverhältnisse einwandfreies
material und ein bisschen glück
sein ballon macht sich schon ein paar
wochen vor ihm auf die lange reise nach
argentinien
wir befinden uns in osttimor
der kleine inselstaat liegt in
südostasien und gehört zu den ärmsten
ländern der welt
heiliger vater ich danke dir für die
menschen die uns unterstützen
ich möchte auch dankbar sein für unser
team ihr beschützer die frauen und
männer die heute eingeliefert wurden und
gibt den ärzten die weisheit um sie
richtig zu behandeln damit sie schnell
gesund werden morgengebet auf dem
flughafen der mission aviation
fellowship kurz enev das christliche
flugunternehmen hilft menschen in not
mit hilfsflügen und mit dem beistand von
ganz oben
vision ist dass mir vor stütze und hilft
bringen und das englisch mit mit der
liebe zu gott und gott höchste daniel
moser arbeitet seit vier jahren als
pilot für die m a f heute muss er sich
um probleme auf einer landepiste kümmern
hier und da müsste man mit dem flughafen
könnte die lage im raum flick 40 ist
natürlich enorm wichtig das mühsame
logfiles of london ist wegen des
fußballers ist es momentan ist der vhv
im schnitt rund 150 meter und da kommt
eine durchsetzen würde mir vor ich suche
daniel hat eigentlich schreiner gelernt
danach ging er als fallschirmaufklärer
mit der swisscoy der schweizer armee in
den kosovo
[Musik]
nach seiner zeit im kosovo feierte
daniel bei der mission aviation
fellowship an die christliche
organisation ist in 26 ländern im
einsatz
dank er konnte sich daniel hier in
osttimor zum missions- piloten ausbilden
lassen
[Musik]
der glaube an die christliche lehre
treibt daniel an gutes zu tun
[Musik]
der christliche glaube spruch etwas mit
der bombe märz via twitter der tipp an
die wand und auf der anderen klub und
ich habe es nicht glauben
damit die damen brachten
osttimor ist ein kleiner inselstaat
zwischen indonesien und australien
die halbinsel hat eine million einwohner
aber nur jeder zweite hat zugang zu
sauberem trinkwasser
ein drittel der bevölkerung ist
arbeitslos
[Musik]
um hilfseinsätze fliegen zu können
müssen die wichtigsten landebahnen in
einem guten zustand sein
diese piste ist nach starken regenfällen
voller schlaglöcher dieses stück hier
muss aufgefüllt und aus nivelliert
werden und vor allem dieser mittelteil
der muss wieder schön gerade sein wie
viel kostet das und wie viel das da
drüben aber bevor daniel dieses problem
lösen kann muss er sich um etwas
dringendes kümmern
ganz in der nähe hat eine frau einen
herzinfarkt erlitten
vielleicht ist es fügung dass der
schweizer zur richtigen zeit am
richtigen ort ist der krankenwagen
bringt die patientin innert minuten zum
flugzeug
sie muss schnellstmöglich ins
krankenhaus
die probleme was hat die patientin für
ein problem brook herzinfarkt daniels
transportflüge können in osttimor leben
retten viele gebiete auf der insel sind
mit dem auto nur schwer erreichbar und
eine fahrt ins nächste krankenhaus würde
stunden dauern
daniel und sein team pflegen vor allem
kranke ältere personen kinder und
neugeborene ohne den flugtransport
könnten diese nicht überleben
der schweizer fliegt die patientin ins
200 kilometer entfernte spital in der
hauptstadt delhi
die maschine fliegt vorbei an bis zu
3000 meter hohen bergen und überquert
dichten regenwald
[Musik]
ja gar nicht gibt wie autos und das mit
der sg lvb medizinischer transfer
formular nicht so genau
dank dieses mal muss ist karola von
deinem
beim herzkatheter natürlich nicht ja
tatsächlich floss so felix und diese
arbeit ist alltag für daniel
[Musik]
er hat gelernt mit den schicksalen denen
er täglich begegnet umzugehen
[Musik]
seit vier jahren fliegt daniel
hilfseinsätze in osttimor
mittlerweile hatte akzeptiert dass das
leben hier nach anderen regeln
funktioniert
aber hinter diesem tor wartet dafür ein
kleines stück heimat auf ihn seine frau
deborah und sony
es gibt für mich natürlich nach so ist
hat eine highlight von target und hohen
schuhen
aber sie schauen wir natürlich auf die
zukunft vorstellt und ist eine erledigte
sache aber hey und das ist doch eine
krasse schritte
ich glaubte schaut bisher wichtig stehen
aber dass das mitgefühl haus durch und
nicht für sich selber bezug zum schluss
meinte so blieb der schnitten hier
bringen schnitten tier sache und die
hebel ist wirklich berechtigt
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite der erdkugel am
fuße der anden liegt der kleine ort os
bada
[Musik]
stefan ist am vorabend angekommen morgen
will er mit seinem heißluftballon zur
fahrt über die anden starten
[Musik]
heute fahren er und die übrigen
ballonfahrer zum base camp auf 2500
meter höhe extrem wichtig das wetter
mussten äste wien im stau kann überhaupt
chancen zum teil des staates auch
sicherheits mäßig und so wiederum man
sich halt das alles und den kaffeefahrt
oder gott sei dank
[Musik]
aber je tiefer der bus ins gebirge fährt
desto schlechter wird das wetter stefan
hatte zwar eine kaltfront erwartet aber
diese aussichten bereiten ihm sorgen
die gruppe erreicht das basecamp in
puente del inc von hier aus wollen die
ballonpiloten am nächsten tag starten
aber stephan hat zweifel
er will sich den startplatz heute noch
ansehen um zu wissen was in morgen
erwartet hast du eine temperaturanzeige
im auto eigentlich wundert sie das
überhaupt domain-namen fahrer lohnt
wir sind hier genau auf einer wetter
grenze wir haben genug wind im norden
aber gegenzügen trichter wind ab bis
runter auf 10 knoten in 6000 metern höhe
das kann ganz heftige turbulenzen geben
ich hoffe wir können überhaupt fliegen
morgen
aber plötzlich werden stefan und seine
begleiter angehalten die argentinische
polizei lässt die gruppe nicht
weiterfahren
der wind hier oben seid so unberechenbar
wo die straßen zu gefährlich ganz klar
stephan und sein team müssen die
wichtige erkundungsfahrt ergebnislos
abbrechen
gerade bei diesem wetter wäre für stefan
eine genaue vorbereitung wichtig gewesen
sich halt irgendwann dem esszimmer sowie
kobe star für oslo casting lichthof das
natürlich in dem moment das auch egal wo
bitte stress produziert
es ist mitternacht reiseführer josef
verspricht allen piloten dass die körbe
und ballone pünktlich am nächsten morgen
eintreffen werden und dass sich das
wetter bessern sollte trotzdem machen
sich viele teilnehmer sorgen als
erfahrener profi versucht stefan die
gruppe etwas zu beruhigen
gewöhnt sind jetzt da wo niederberger
mit mir reden halten war nicht mehr nach
witzen in for peace ist werden
keiner denkt daran ins bett zu gehen
noch bis tief in die nacht wird weiter
diskutiert ob die spektakuläre
ballonfahrt über die anden am nächsten
tag tatsächlich stattfinden kann steht
in den sternen
[Musik]
durban in südafrika die pc 12 hat
wertvolle fracht an bord
dann ging's dann alles ist gut kommt
setzt sich auf junge du hast ein
bisschen heißt das baby und seine mutter
haben den 90 minütigen flug gut
überstanden sagt tschüss zu unserem zwei
piloten
sie haben dich sicher nach durban
geflogen und ein leben zu retten
du wirst uns sicher vermissen
kingston wird noch am gleichen tag am
herzen operiert er wird den eingriff
besten überstehen
[Musik]
ja wir sind auf dem weg
runde
[Musik]
zwei stunden später mischa ist zurück in
mauern und hat endlich feierabend
zu hause wartet ihr mann christian
bereits mit dem nachtessen
[Musik]
aber zum essen kommt mir trotzdem noch
nicht ein safari ranger kommt vorbei es
ist nur hier der arm der nicht sehr groß
setz dich dahin ich schaue mir schnell
an der ranger wurde von einer spinne
gebissen
jetzt
du brauchst eine infusion antibiotika
schmerzmittel und einem whiskey schau
diese pillen habe ich gestern in der
apotheke gekauft
ja diese nichts tut sogar noch mehr wie
es ist ich bin bis so schwerwiegende
krankheitsbilder machen liegt meist
daran dass sie in ihrer gefährlichkeit
gar nicht erkannt werden und das kann
ganz ganz böse ausgehen wenn man das
nicht mit antibiotika aggressiv
behandelt
das ist unglaublich wie sehr so etwas
kleines schmerzt es fühlt sich an als ob
es bis auf den knochen runtergingen ja
das würde vielen dank und zum wohl auf
eure gesundheit aus
und nächste woche bei schweizer helden
der lüfte
kraus vor der erste ballonfahrt in
argentinien
stefan findet seine sauerstoffflasche
make up stellen
wir haben jetzt wenigstens mal
hauptkunde sascha und dominik jahren
ihrem ersten tor hinterher und geraten
in eine gewitterzelle
[Musik]
jonas trifft auf den großmeister des
segelfliegens oder lebt eine
enttäuschung ohne scared heizlüfter
scheiße
und auch mischa und daniel heben wieder
ab um leben zu retten
[Musik]